(audience cheering)
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ She, she ain't real ♪
♪ She ain't gon' be able
to love you like I will ♪
♪ She is a stranger ♪
♪ You and I have history
or don't you remember ♪
♪ Sure, she's got it all ♪
♪ But, baby, is that
really what you want ♪
♪ Well, bless your soul ♪
♪ You got your head in the clouds ♪
♪ She made a fool out of you ♪
♪ And, boy, she's bringing you down ♪
♪ She made your heart melt ♪
♪ But you're cold to the core ♪
♪ Now rumor has it she ain't
got your love anymore ♪
♪ Rumor has it, rumor ♪
♪ Rumor has it ♪
♪ All of these words whispered in my ear ♪
♪ Tell a story that I
cannot bear to hear ♪
♪ Just 'cause I said it ♪
♪ It don't mean that I meant it ♪
♪ Oh, rumor has it, rumor ♪
♪ Rumor has it, rumor ♪
♪ Oh, rumor has it he's the
one I'm leaving you for ♪
(audience cheering)